A
little pause...
and we are back.
A little pause... and we are back.
Hello, hello everybody!
Hey guys!
Hello everybody!
Welcome to Cookie Run Kingdoms!
A huge shoutout to Cookie Run for sponsoring today's stream.
You guys can see in the description below.
I do have links that you can click to use to install Cookie Run to help support the stream and the game!
So please feel free to click on the links.
Or that's pinned in the comments.
It really does help a lot.
Because it helps, you know, encourages more sponsors in the future and everything.
So yeah!
Daniel Cookie Run Kingdom today!
Even though you haven't seen me play it yet!
You know?
Just because you haven't seen me play it doesn't mean that's going to stop you from downloading it right now!
So you can play along with me, you know?
Play along with me guys!
But yes, again, a very huge shoutout again to Cookie Run for reaching out to me.
Especially because I've never... I've never... Yes, supporting your streamers blindly is the way to go.
Good things always happen when you support somebody blindly with no evidence.
But you know I'm going to make this game look great!
I'm also trying very hard not to swear because like this game is very... very...
very...
Dude, this game is way too cute to swear right now.
So I have my inner filters on.
Okay, let me bring down the music just a little bit and then we're good to go.
Alright!
So I've actually... I've actually never played Cookie Run before.
I've always seen a lot about this game.
And I know they have like a lot of different games.
This like... it has like a different types of games as well.
It's not just kingdoms.
But this is actually my very, very first time playing Cookie Run.
I always loved the designs of Cookie Run.
Like I've seen like... especially Cookie Run Kingdom.
I've always loved the designs because I mean...
This guy is so freaking cute.
I hesitated because I had to vote.
I almost went for it.
But apparently...
This cookie is called Cream Barret Cookie.
And they look really, really cute.
And I always think like all the designs are actually like really adorable and everything.
And...
I know the Cookie Run fandom is also very big and very fanatical too regarding...
Because it was so funny.
I was looking at...
Also, I turned down the music already.
So let me know if it's better.
But it was so funny because...
Cookie Run retweeted my tweet.
And then I was looking at the tweet replies.
And then people were just like...
Oh my god, does this mean...
Does this mean you're gonna add dragons into Cookie Run?
So I thought it was so cute.
They like have their own fandom and everything.
And like have like fan art and stuff like that.
It's like...
It's really cute.
I thought it was like really, really cute.
Alright, I'll turn down the music a little bit more again.
Let me know if it's a lot better.
But yes!
Apparently there is...
There is a new update.
In this game.
Called My Cookie.
And that is what we're gonna be checking out.
I will be using an account that Cookie Run has given me.
And...
You know what that means.
Free gacha pulls.
I love free stuff.
I haven't...
Let's go gambling!
Done gacha in a long, long time.
So...
That should mean...
I have stockpiled my gacha luck into it.
To pull some sick ass...
Is ass a swear?
Okay, I don't know.
It's a body part.
So it shouldn't be.
But some sick ass...
Cookies.
Even though I have no idea if my cookies are rare or not.
But like...
That's the best part.
If it's a bad pull.
I'll still be happy.
So...
Oh wait, you're right.
A lot of body parts are considered a force.
I swear.
But...
There is a...
There is a lot of stuff in this new update.
I was told.
So there is apparently...
There's a town square now.
And then there's like the my cookie design feature.
Where you can basically customize your own cookie-sona.
So your own...
So it's like a fursona.
But what if you're a cookie?
So you could be like that gingerbread man.
In Shrek.
I think.
I don't know.
Wait!
Oh my god.
I mean it's literally a gingerbread man.
So it's...
You could be your own cookie-sona!
So...
You can make your own cookie-sona.
And...
In the my cookie.
So it's either called icing.
That can be earned from various things.
Like sugarcoat cookie salon.
The weaving shop.
Or certain events.
Or even shop packages.
I can buy so many cosmetics.
Oh my god.
I haven't checked yet how much money I have.
In the account they gave me.
So I'm gonna spend it all.
I need to make my cookie-sona.
Um...
And yes.
And also the new special cookie as you see here.
Look at this giant ass ferret cookie.
Apparently that is a half...
Half furry, half cookie.
Cause they are the cream ferret cookie.
Oh my god.
The amount of times I've said...
The amount of times I've said cookie.
Biscuit.
Alright for all you people out there.
A cookie is like a biscuit.
So you can make your own biscuit-sonas.
I'm very diverse.
I'm very inclusive.
Um...
But yes.
I'm very excited.
There's also like a limited gacha banner called...
Summer Vacay Costumes.
As well as some limited time events.
So let's go check this out.
There was an intro.
I have not entered the game.
Because like when I entered.
There was an intro.
So like there was a cutscene.
So I was scared of like...
I was scared that if I click on...
If I went in fully.
I would miss the cutscene.
And I don't know if it's important.
I don't know if it's important to the cookie lore.
So let's get right into it.
But yes.
Huge shout out again to Cookie Run for sponsoring this stream.
I really really do appreciate it guys.
Um...
Alright let's go in.
Hello.
Connecting.
Also I brought music down already.
Sound guide.
Let me know if it's better now.
Hey.
I heard a lot of people spent a lot of money on this game.
Is that true?
Any Cookie Run enthusiasts?
Willing to tell me how much they spent?
And...
Even if you're not proud of it?
Uh...
Yes.
Oh my god.
There's narration?
That's great.
I don't have to read.
Holy shit.
A thousand dollars?
Holy shoot.
A thousand...
The filter did not work for me when I saw that amount.
I'm sorry.
I saw that amount and my filter stopped working.
A king needs entertainment.
Wait is that the king?
Is this the king of Cookie Run?
Custard Cookie the third.
Are all the kings custards?
Who let this child be the third?
The king!
Ha ha ha ha ha ha!
Ha ha ha ha ha!
It's carrying something heavy!
Like a chest full of shit!
No that's a king!
Custard Cookie time is money!
Maybe...
Tell him to go away!
Where is she going?
She's really speedy when there's treasure involved.
Wait if he's not the king...
Then who gave him the crown?
A blueberry!
You're not a cookie!
Who let this bird in here?
Ha ha ha ha ha!
This is a Cookie Run kingdom!
Who let this bird in here?
That's my treasure you're talking about!
What
is that?
That's ice cream.
This is a baby!
That's a baby?
Where did you bring this little cookie from?
That's a baby!
That's a baby?
Ha ha ha ha ha!
What is that?
Oh my god!
Oh!
A letter from BeardCraft!
Oh it's a cookie dough!
That means you baked the baby!
It's
a cookie!
That's so cute.
That's actually really smart.
Oh my god you put the baby...
Oh my...
Someone put that baby in the oven!
Ha ha ha ha!
What if I microwave the baby?
Alright, CustardCookieThe3rd and friends of the Cookie Kingdom.
Oh my god!
We met this cute little buddy while on our adventure!
So cute!
Unfortunately, where we're headed is not safe for a doughy little...
Oh my god!
We met this cute little buddy while on our adventure!
They abandoned their baby!
That's messed up!
They just owned the baby.
They put it in the orphanage.
Oh my god!
It's like in those shows where they leave the baby at the doorstep.
And be like, take care of it.
That's his baby?
Who did GingerBrave...
put the baby in the oven for?
The baby!
Wait, so is he a pretend king?
Because he says, into my kingdom.
Who's the baker?
Yeah.
Who will this baby become?
Oh, he's like a pretend king.
I see.
Aww.
Let bro think he's a king.
Goo goo ga ga.
This is why you got disowned.
He's...
He's like, it's your problem now.
Someone freaking...
I'm sorry, the baby got me.
Someone throw this baby into the oven.
So we can speed the process.
That can talk?
You're an animal.
Who are you?
Is that the fairy?
The baby's a fairy.
I don't care who you are.
Pass the baby.
Oh god.
Now sweet little cookie.
Please.
I need to skip the baby.
Following the blue bird to this very place to help you little one.
Look at my fluffy cream tail.
So soft and bouncy.
Are they gonna put the ferret and the cookie dough in the oven together?
Oh my god.
They're gonna get fur on the cookie dough.
You did it!
It's gonna eat you now.
Wait, it grew?
How it's still there?
Poof?
What?
Oh!
Everything I...
Everything I was taught about Cookie Run in the last ten minutes.
Gone.
They... they work.
Is it, like, a werewolf?
I'm a cream ferret.
That doesn't answer...
Are you a cookie?
The cream critters?
Mind you.
Eh,
cookie...
Oh, it is a Persona!
Oh!
He... the... okay, the ferret turned into... I thought... I thought they fused!
I thought... I legit... I thought... I legit... I thought they fused.
I was like, wait, what happened?
Oh, hey!
Okay, I get it.
This person can turn into an animal.
I get it.
Just because they're like a free babysitter.
You're not leaving the baby!
Wait, did we skip already?
Did we skip a couple... Oh my...
Where's the baby?
One strong cookie hug coming right up!
It says taller!
Clearly not tall enough!
I'm happy if you're happy.
God, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
You're gonna grow up bigger and stronger than yesterday!
Oh my...
At least I'm taller than the baby!
Yeah, because we can't even see the baby!
Right?
Tooth... Toothing-less baby dough.
Wait!
The cookies have teeth?
The cookie run in Kingdom Lore is so deep.
I didn't even realize they have teeth.
Where's the baby?
Where did the baby go?
Oh, Tooth-sing!
Oh, it's like a tooth-sing with the icing!
It's icing tea!
Oh!
I get you!
Tooth-sing?
I get it!
Does that mean there's a tooth fairy?
There's a tooth-sing?
Tooth-sing?
Oh my god.
There's a tooth-sing fairy?
Alright now, let's toss your tooth-sing up on the roof!
Wait, the blueberry bird is the tooth-sing fairy?
Oh no...
Oh no!
No, don't follow the false king!
He's a fake!
No!
The thing spoke!
Monster!
Burn the cookie!
It's only been a day!
There's something wrong with that baby!
Where's the frickin'... Oh, that's me!
Don't burn the cookie!
It's me!
Hey!
I'm gonna get... I'm gonna get... Don't burn the cookie!
I... No!
There's a baby on the log!
No!
I got disowned!
I'm an orphan!
Turn off the oven!
Turn it off!
I'm an orphan!
What a plot!
Everything I said about the baby, I was just joking!
Hee-hee!
Ha-ha!
I don't really need a cook!
Do I get to dress up my cookie?
Whoa!
Welcome my cookie update!
The town square is back!
Complete in the quiz game!
Cream ferret cookie is here!
New season of Arab Busters in the Kaku Town Square!
New darkness artifact in Cookie Alliance!
Dressed for the...
Oh, this one!
This is a new gacha that they have!
Oh my god!
Wait, I can be a ferret too!
Okay, and then there's like this...
Oh, the cookie run tower!
Oh yeah, this is the newest event!
Alright...
Special!
Wait, can I...
Oh!
How much do I have?
Oh, I have...
Wait, I can...
What happens if I wake her up?
Oh!
I'll wake her up.
I have enough money.
Are you awake?
Wake up.
Wake up!
Keep trying.
I won't stop!
Wake up!
What do you mean?
I thought you were my babysitter!
Are you serious?
You're supposed to be my babysitter!
What's shake up?
Oh, I shouldn't shake up.
I don't want to shake up.
I don't think I have enough.
It's not fair!
You're supposed to babysit me!
Oh, just because I grew up, you're going to stop babysitting me?
Just because I'm not a baby anymore!
That's so messed up.
Wait, can I attempt on the snapdragon cookie?
No, I can't!
I did it, Nerdy!
This is not fair!
Also, I need to fix the volume, so give me a sec.
Let me...
Just because I'm not a baby anymore, they think they can just leave?
Okay, I turned down the music again.
I'll still turn down the effects too.
It's so messed up.
I can't believe it.
I can't believe it would do such a thing.
How many crystals do I have?
Yes, by the way, like I said, huge shout out to...
I didn't know...
Huge shout out to the Cookie Run for giving me an account because I never played Cookie Run before.
Oh my god, there's so many things to do.
My name is Yeast Powder.
Oh my god, there's so many things.
Oh yeah, there's a town square!
Wait, are those all the other cookies?
Oh, is this my house?
Is that a cookie?
Oh, these are my cookies!
Oh my god!
This is my town!
That's a lot!
Yeah.
Wait, not daffy, sorry!
Daisy?
There's a daisy?
There's a daisy cookie?
Wait, is there...
Oh, is this like...
I got special!
Oh!
Oh my god!
I'm rich!
Oh my...
I don't even pick up money!
How many cookies do I have?
Oh, there's Default Dan!
There's Gingerbread Man!
There's Default Dan!
Oh my god, there's babies!
Who put these gnomes in my...
Oh wait, no, they're just decorations.
Sorry, that's just decoration.
Oh my god, I'm gonna spend all the money!
Sorry!
This is not even what I'm supposed to show you guys.
Sorry, I got...
I got really curious about the decorations and everything.
Wait, oh my god, there's...
Wait, you're not a cookie?
You're just goofy!
You're literally...
You're literally just...
What are you doing here?
You're not even a cookie...
You're not even cookie shaped.
You're not...
Who let these Disney characters...
into my cookie game?
Gosh.
Gosh Sora.
It seems that...
the Keyblade took us to Cookie Run.
You're not...
You're not edible!
Alright, we gotta...
go to Town Square.
Because that is like apparently the...
newest features that they did.
If I could see it.
Wait, you look rather frazzled.
It's okay.
It's okay, some...
It's okay, just a little...
Busy?
I'm busy.
We're just here for the audio.
I'm full of crisp pills.
It's loading.
You're just too funny, Chili Pepper Cookie.
Who's this...
This here is an invitation I made.
Oh really?
Where is it?
That's right.
We do have a festival to celebrate the reopening of the Town Square.
Oh!
The festival!
Please do come.
As we're making...
Charisma.
Charisma's my old friend.
Oh my God.
Oh, okay, there we go.
Oh, a Gojo Sim.
How can I get a Choco-Choc without...
Hey guys.
I'm new here.
Yeah.
How do I move?
Oh, here it is.
Hey, I'm Yuspowder!
Hey, everybody!
Hey, luck is on my side today!
Hey, guys!
Oh my god!
That's my cookie!
Hey, everybody!
What do they use to type in RuneScape?
We'll chop wood for gold.
Oh god!
Wait!
I think...
I think I...
Oh my god!
Why is there a lizard in my cookie kingdom?
Why is there a lizard there?
There's a guy called I hate cookies.
Wait!
Buying cookies for 10...
Buying cookies for 10 cookies.
Buying 10 cookie bab...
Oh shit!
No, that's not it.
Sorry, that's my live chat.
Buying cookies for cookie babies.
Cookie babies for 10...
For 10 cookie.
Hello, everybody.
Oh my god!
The paparazzi!
Guys!
The paparazzi is here!
Oh no!
No photos!
The jig is up.
I'm not...
Doki.
Cookie on yeast powder!
What are you guys talking about?
On yeast powder!
Oh, there's like villager assistant cheese bird.
Oh, I wanna redecorate my cookie.
Do I leave here?
Leaving town square.
Sorry guys.
I need to redecorate my cookie.
Oh, I should turn up the...
Let me... settings.
Okay, let me turn down the music a little bit more.
And then turn up the volume.
Alright, let me know if that's better.
Okay.
Oops, that's not what I wanted.
Oh, okay.
Oh, my cookie!
There we go.
Oh!
Do I have everything?
How do I...
Eyes really...
Oh, closet!
Closet!
Oh my god, I have so many.
Do I?
Oh, I have...
Wait.
I don't have enough.
Equip.
Oh, I have a hat!
I'm so cool.
And then...
I like the face.
I think the face is perfect.
Oh my, there's so many.
Wait, there's lips?
You can change your lip tone as many times as you want.
Just move the slider.
Oh!
So I can like match the lip tone.
Okay, I wanna keep this.
I think this was perfect.
And then...
We're gonna...
There we go.
Yeah.
Alright.
Let's see.
I wanna be...
Wait.
I wanna...
What kind of cookies do I...
I don't wanna be...
I don't wanna be a gingerbread...
Well...
I wanna be a...
A normal biscuit.
Do I have voices?
Oh!
Oh, my god.
Um...
I have like custom voices.
I like how he's like...
Um...
I was just like...
What?
You guys heard that?
Okay,
I actually like the default.
Oh, save.
What is this?
You have no icing equipped.
Oh!
Okay.
Oh, I don't have any other eyes?
Thank you.
Oh, and then...
Wait, what is this?
Okay, these are my eyes.
Oh, my god.
Wait.
Alright.
That's cute.
That's cute though.
Oh, and then...
Oh, my god.
Can I...
Oh!
That's cute.
What hair do I have though?
I'm trying to figure out what hair I have.
Is this the hair I have?
I need a specific icing.
Oh, this item is available...
Uh...
For a limited time only.
Oh!
I see.
But I can't change the...
Can I change the color?
I can't change the color?
Oh, I see.
Oh!
Wait, what's this?
Honest work bandage.
Oh no, that...
Nah, I don't need that.
Alright, what are my shoes?
Ooh, I think this one looks really nice.
The shoe.
Why am I a waiter?
I don't wanna be a waiter.
I was like, why am I a waiter?
Wait, how...
Which outfit is this?
Oh, it's this outfit.
I'm not gonna be a waiter.
I'm gonna... I'm not gonna be...
I'm not gonna be a goddamn waiter.
I'm a cool kid.
I'm gonna be so cool.
No, I could be preppy!
With the money...
I'm gonna be preppy!
Alright, let's see.
Yeah...
My dad can buy your house.
My dad is your dad.
Boss!
Okay, let me change the hat to match it too.
Okay, we gotta remove the hat.
Remove.
There we go.
Wait, unless...
A blueberry cap.
Yeah.
Unless I get more...
Yeah, I'm the private school cookie.
So punchable.
My dad works in Cookie Run!
That's me.
Why is it polite cookie?
That is definitely not what I was going for.
Oh, okay.
Wait, wait, wait.
I could change the name.
Okay.
16 bites.
Ivy League.
I'm trying to...
I wanna know like what kind of cookie...
Polite and...
In parentheses.
Trust...
No!
I can't use trust!
No, they're right.
They're right.
They're right though.
Okay.
All right.
I'm nipple baby cookie.
Okay.
Here.
This is...
This is my cookie.
I would do private school cookie if I had enough characters.
I have the money.
I have so much private school cookies.
Alright guys, do I get Nepo baby cookie or private school cookie?
Which one?
Okay, Nepo.
Alright, we gotta get more cosmetics though.
We gotta get... what is this?
Is this a gacha?
Oh, these are for the outfits!
Right?
Oh, it's the limited time!
Okay, draw five.
Do I have enough?
Oh, I have...
Guys!
Oh my god, guys.
I wonder if I have enough, guys.
Okay.
Let's go.
Open up!
Oh?
Oh my god, we're putting the baby in the oven!
Draw?
Oh.
What is that?
A-S-S-N-E-P-O baby cookie!
Pick toes.
Oh, I got the mint donut!
Focktail!
You can't afford it.
Is that legendary?
Did I get the legendary?
Oh, I got another pink!
I hope this sounds a lot better now.
Alright, draw.
Draw my cookie.
What did I get?
I got a ribbon, I got shorts...
I don't need sunglasses.
Mysterious Milky Way hair dye.
Oh!
I can like change the hair color!
Do I have everything?
No, I'm missing like three...
Three, four, five.
It's okay, I can keep going.
Alright, am I gonna get it?
Oh, no.
Oh!
I like that hairstyle.
I'm still missing!
It's okay, we can keep going.
Ripped bottoms...
My dad would not like that.
Ripped bottoms does not go with the dress code.
I should be gacha-ing for the characters.
Like, I think I'm making regular Cookie Run players really sad.
Because I'm doing gacha on my cookie instead of like...
You know...
I'm doing gacha on my cookie instead of on the characters.
Here it is.
RIP bottoms.
RIP bottoms does not follow the dress code in my private school.
Oh, it's a separate currency?
Okay.
That's good.
Oh, that's great.
Okay.
A little cookie run.
Alright, let's see.
What do I have here?
Oh, is that another rare?
Draw the cookie!
What did I get?
Oh!
Sound of the sea?
Oh, it's for like when I'm holding it.
Oh, I got this.
Okay, I was gonna say.
Oh my god!
My dad's gonna love it when I wear these two outfits.
I don't know.
I think I got like... what's regular?
Oh, so like you can just choose the outfit you want.
Oh, I can just straight up buy stuff.
Oh!
Check out our catalog.
Alright, I wanna see what I can get in the regular.
What does the magic conch say?
Oh, I got another rare!
Let's see.
What did I get?
Oh, I got a book!
That's when you know I'm smart.
I got a...
Is there stain on my white tank top?
My...
My stain on my...
My tank top.
Okay, closet time.
Alright, let's see.
Wait, you can read?
Okay, now I'm gonna definitely put on the book.
This does match it more though.
Yes, I can read.
I go to private school.
Oh, this is almost free.
I see.
Oh my god.
Oh, you can even read the word stuff.
This is so interesting!
It's so typical fanboying, actually.
This is crazy.
And...
Save in the library?
Oh, it's a protection lock so I don't accidentally...
Oh!
I see!
Yeah, you know what?
That's very smart because I would definitely do that.
I would definitely do that.
That's very smart.
Wait, do I get a bow?
Oh, it's like a tail thing.
What's this?
Oh no, I don't like that.
I want like...
I want like a...
Nice...
Preppy shoes.
I need like some preppy shoes.
No, those are sneakers.
Dad won't like that.
Oh, everything is mine to equip.
Oh, okay.
I want to make sure like...
What's the difference between...
Oh, this is yellow stitch.
Wait, what's the difference between these two pants?
They look quite similar.
What about shirts?
Do I have any new shirts?
No, okay.
Oh, the white tank top.
What is this?
Am I wearing a freaking paper...
Toilet paper?
Oh, there's doubles.
Oh, you can get doubles?
I'm lucky then.
I'm very lucky.
All right.
What's the gotcha?
Oh.
What currency do I have?
I think I need more.
I think...
Oh, no.
I have to be very careful.
All right.
So, apparently...
Oh, wait.
What is the difference between...
Vaky Cookie Gotcha...
and Gotcha Fate?
Vaky Cookie Gotcha.
What is the difference between cookies and limited?
One is limited.
Vaky Cookie Gotcha.
Limited versus standard.
Thanks, guys.
One is limited.
Vaky Cookie Gotcha.
Oh, but they're so...
Oh, these are costumes.
You can dress up your cookies.
I get it.
I don't know if I have those cookies.
We're gone, Tier?
Hey, Cookie Run.
It would be funny if like, you know, I hide my screen for a little bit and suddenly I have like a hundred thousand cookie cutters.
That would be so silly though, wouldn't it, Cookie Run?
So silly.
Anyway, guys, I might need to hide my screen in five minutes.
Wait, did I get two autumn leaves?
Okay.
Wait, I didn't get any of the new costumes!
This is not summer vacation!
He's wearing a tuxedo!
I was on summer vacation!
Alright, let's see.
What did I get?
Did I get any rares?
Wait, they have a gnome wizard cookie?!
Wait, they have... Okay, that's...
They have the gnome wizard cookie!
Please!
Please don't give me... I haven't done gacha in so long!
Why am I not getting summer vacation?!
Why not?
I got gnomed.
I can't believe it.
Alright.
Oh!
I got two!
Oh my god.
Conductor's summer...
Wow, Desert's so cool!
She's so cute!
We already have her?!
Okay.
It's a thought that counts, guys.
It's a thought.
I didn't know I already have her!
Who's this?
Blast the heat wave away...
Oh!
I really love her hair.
Her hair color.
It's so pretty.
I love like it's so aesthetically pleasing to look at.
Oh my god.
What the heck is...
What the...
Okay, I also like this guy too.
This guy goes to the gym.
This guy...
This guy is definitely getting some gains.
Someone put some...
Someone put some bacon in that cookie.
Do I have all of them?
Technically?
I wonder like...
How can I tell if I...
Uh...
Have all of them?
I really...
I actually really like these two the most.
So I'm glad I got them.
Like, I'm sorry you...
Oh my god.
This guy definitely goes to private school.
Oh...
This...
This guy definitely goes to private...
Probability?
I have...
Oh, I'm literally only missing him!
I'm missing private school kid!
1% Ken Brulee.
What am I missing?
Okay.
I am missing...
I'm actually missing...
Okay, I guess we have to.
I wonder if I can take his clothes...
And like...
Put it on my cookie.
Oh!
It's so cute!
I love the hoodie.
Wait, is this another gnome?
This is like...
I don't want to get that go to school gnome.
I want to steal his fit.
Give me private school!
I want private school guy!
I want Ken Brulee!
Oh, I got another gnome.
Come on!
Oh!
Who are you?
What the heck are you?
You're not my summer vacation.
You're a pomegranate cookie.
Who puts pomegranate in their cookie?
Freak.
Guys, I'm sorry.
I know there's like game content.
But like...
I need Ken Brulee.
Ken?
Ken, is that you?
Okay, wait.
Cookie.
Okay, you're cute.
Okay, I know you're cute.
But I got to complete the set.
I got to complete the set.
Oh my god.
Two elasties.
Oh, she's cute.
The royal knight's cute.
Oh, she's cute too!
Please.
Where's Ken?
Where are you?
How much money do I have left?
How much?
Wait.
Oh no, now I get all whites.
Oh no.
How much?
Oh, that's fine.
I don't have to worry.
I can do this for as long as I want.
I can do this.
For as long as I want.
Please!
I just need one more!
Oh!
What?
What are you?
Is that even a cookie anymore?
Is that...
Is that even a cookie?
Is that even...
Is that...
That's like...
Oh, you know what?
I found out.
I found out centaurs have like two chests.
Because they have a chest right here.
And then they have a chest right here too.
So like...
It's weird.
It like messed me up a little bit.
Come on.
Summer?
Yeah, two rib cages.
Yeah, that's what I mean.
Sorry, I'm not a biologist.
Ken?
Yeah!
I did it!
It only took like a thousand dollars.
If I actually...
It's okay.
It only took like maybe $500.
With the polls.
But that's okay.
Now I have the cookie that perfectly represents me.
Alright, so guys, let me like hide my...
No, I'm joking.
I won't hide my screen.
Wait, what's the difference between...
Wait, do I have all of them?
We aren't that... Oh yeah, you're right.
Sorry.
It only took $10, guys.
$10... I don't know how many pulls I did.
I don't know how...
I've lost count!
I lost count how many pulls I did.
Oh, did I found all of them?
No, I didn't.
There's like stuff I haven't found there.
There's epic.
There's ancient.
It's like $0.30 worth of pulls I did.
Guys, that was like $0.30 by the way.
How do I know like what I...
Oh, I can found...
Oh, creme brulee cookie!
I have that!
I have milk... Oh, it shows here!
Oh!
I have the cookies!
Oh, I have all the god cookies!
I just can't read.
I never can.
Alright, I wanna get...
I have all... Oh, I have all of them!
They're the... They're the... The summer VK!
I'm gonna get the... This, guys.
Oh...
I don't have a lot of that.
That means I'm gonna spend it.
I don't have a lot, so I'm gonna spend...
Oh!
Oh, I'm pressing?
Is that a magical?
I got good pull, yeah!
It's sparkled!
What are you?
Oh, it's the gnome guy!
With a lollipop!
Oh, is this the rare?
It's the magical one!
It's a rainbow!
Who are you?
Oh...
I got gnomed.
I got god.
Mystic Flower Cookie.
Wait, is that good?
Is that... I thought I just automatically get a...
I don't know.
I'm just... I...
Every time I do gacha, I get a... I thought these... It's just normal.
I thought that was just normal, guys.
I...
I don't know, guys.
After you watch this stream and do gacha, you'll get my luck.
I told you!
I stockpiled all my gacha luck!
Oh my god, I got the...
If we combine the gnome and the wizard cookie together, we'll get the gnome wizard.
Oh, is she?
Nice.
I'm just that good.
Oh, the knight cookies.
Oh, beast!
Nice.
I did it.
She's so cute.
She's so pretty.
I...
Sorry, I got really absorbed in the...
In the gacha.
Anyway, it's time for more gacha.
It's...
Anyway...
It's time...
Sorry, I got very absorbed with the gacha.
Anyway, guys.
Wait, I want to...
I want to...
Get out of here.
Okay.
I need...
My cookie needs more clothes.
Guys, I know...
Like...
There's other stuff I have to do.
But I need to make sure my cookie is like dressed appropriately.
I need...
Guys, I...
Oh my god, wait the...
I go...
Wait...
Wait, I love...
Why is there...
Why is...
Why can you make your cookie a ball thing?
This is important, guys.
Oh, I got curly hair.
That's prep material!
Okay, we gotta use the...
Okay, let's see.
Busy...
Oh, we...
We haven't done this enough.
Nope.
Come on.
You really aren't...
This is nuts.
I'm so...
I'm sorry.
My dad like bought me so many cookies.
I don't know which one is the special one anymore.
Because they're all like normal to me.
Like...
Oh my god, wait.
That...
Okay.
What golden dookie on the sticky?
Don't hurt me like this.
Is that the...
How am I getting none of the new icings?
I'm so sorry.
Is that...
Oh no, that's not.
Oh, there it is!
That has to be...
Why am I...
Okay, I have one of them.
I have one of them.
Okay.
I just want to collect more.
I just want to make sure I have more of it.
I need more clothes!
How else am I gonna like...
Make my cookie look amazing?
Oh, that's really cute.
I like that.
All right.
Let's see.
I have like five of these hats.
I think I'm gonna get...
I think the...
What's the black cap?
I think the black cap...
Suits it a lot better.
I need like black shades.
I just need black shades and then it'll be perfect.
All right let me make see like...
In my...
In my little...
I have like fucking...
Freaking six shirts.
Sorry.
I saw too many shirts.
I'm sorry.
I just had too many red shirts.
I'm sorry!
There are just so many!
There are too many shirts!
I couldn't help it.
Oh, yes!
You guys didn't hear anything, guys.
Okay.
I feel like... I don't know, is this... Yes, I feel like this is definitely...
How do I change the color?
Is it the weave?
Right?
It's the... Oh, save.
How do I change the color of my hair?
They allow those... My dad is on the board of directors.
So of course they're gonna allow me.
Is it... Is it gacha?
Just click?
Oh, it's gacha too?
Oh, so like I have to get the...
Uh...
Where's all these colors?
Ooh!
Mystery.
Oh, you want to change it?
Oh!
They are random guaranteed and seasonal hair dyes.
I see!
Okay, that's not... That's so cute!
Okay, I want...
I feel like black hair would be... make more sense though.
Right?
I'm trying to figure out... Guys, I'm sorry.
This is like very important to me.
Like...
Yes.
Okay, you know what?
Perfect.
Okay, we're good.
Alright.
I think... I think my cookie... Okay.
I think my cookie is ready to go to school.
I'm gonna make sure I have everything I want.
You know what?
Maybe I should change the pants color.
Black?
No.
Blue is better.
Yeah.
Alright.
Nice.
It's time to go to the town square.
I want... I want to show everybody my drip!
A gift has arrived?
Hey guys.
My dad owns Cookie Run.
Nah.
Whoa!
That's right.
My dad owns Cookie Run.
Nice.
Oh, and I can complete missions and farm currency?
Oh, I can complete missions?
I want to talk to this guy.
Hello there.
Oh, okay.
Whoa!
Oh my god!
It's France!
No!
Oh my god.
I'm getting... I'm getting... I mean...
People of Revolution.
Run, Cookie Run.
Oh my god.
There's gifts!
I want my reward.
My free gift.
I definitely need it.
Which is the best one?
I have 6000 of that.
How much do I have of this?
I can't tell.
I have 27000.
Oh, I have less of this.
I'll take that.
You're never rich.
I'm yeast powder.
That's me.
I'm a fashion icon.
Oh my god.
Everybody is like...
Dressed to impress right now.
They're on.
Oh wait.
Where's your...
Oh, I can do emojis?
That's right.
Where are the missions?
I can jump?
Oh, I can slide.
Wait.
Okay, wait.
I'm sorry.
Sorry.
It's the little things.
It's the little things that get me.
I'm gonna slide.
Where's the...
Where's some of the missions?
Here.
Oh, quests.
Okay.
Daily quests.
Did I complete any?
No, I...
Oh, I have!
Yeah!
I did it!
I did my job.
Yeah, I did some emos.
Wait, can I dance?
Oh my god.
Guys!
Please!
No paparazzis!
I wanna dance!
Guys!
No paparazzi!
I need a dance!
Let me dance!
Okay.
Yeah!
Eat the eat!
Oh my god!
I can dance too!
No pictures!
No pictures everybody!
I gotta dance!
I can't believe they wouldn't let me dance!
Alright.
That's cute though.
I like how everybody's fit.
Everybody's...
has such cute clothes.
Oh, you can hide the chat here.
Everybody's clothes are so cute.
Oh my god, look at...
Oh my god!
It's the wizard!
It's the gnome wizard!
He didn't move it.
Oh, jelly worm?
Where's the jelly worm?
Jelly worm?
Are you the...
You're the jelly lizard!
Are you a worm?
Something's wrong.
I don't know how many times I was pondered over.
Oh, silly me.
Oh no, that's not the jelly worm.
That's the jelly lizard.
Where are the jelly worms?
Oh no, she can't read.
Guys, I need to find the jelly worm.
Oh, it's on the right side!
Thank you, I don't have eyes.
I can't see it with all...
with all the money in front of me.
Are you the jelly worm?
Is that...
I can't...
Are you...
You're the granola cookie.
Oh, it's Smiley Jelly Worm!
It's because everybody was there!
I found...
I found them.
Oh my god, you're so tiny!
Fulfill 10 wishes?
Okay.
I'm gonna do that.
Fulfill 10 wishes from the tree.
Okay, and then this is...
Clay Mail Reward.
Oh, I can do that!
Where's the mailbox?
Mail Reward.
Oh my god.
Where's my mail?
Oh, there it is!
Down here!
I see it!
Who left my mail on the floor?
Smithers?
I wonder what's inside the vault.
Something 5.
Is that my mail?
It has to be my mail, right?
Oh, there's a key here!
Guys, what's the code?
You only get 3...
Guys, who did it?
Guys, we know the third number is 3, guys.
We know...
We know the third number is...
Is 5.
5.
Guys, we gotta work together!
Oh, nice!
Okay, no!
Thanks guys!
Guys, we did it!
Together!
We did it!
Nice!
Team work.
I did it.
Guys...
Yippee!
I did it.
Oh, is it this?
Alright, claim.
I did my quest.
I did, I claimed it.
I claimed it.
Quest complete.
Oh, nice!
All me.
Oh, there's no request.
Okay.
Quest.
And now...
Claim mail reward.
Oh, it's in the town square.
What the heck is a mailbox?
Oh, I have to claim all?
Oh, nice.
Okay.
Make your choice.
I want...
Ungabunga string.
I always wanna be strong.
Alright, I did it.
I did it, Mr. Silkworm!
Or Smart Jellyworm.
Sorry, Smart Jellyworm.
Talk to me.
That's so hard to see.
Did I not...
Did I not get it?
Guys.
Where's my mailbox?
I'm not used to...
Guys, I'm not used to having a mailbox, guys.
Why mailbox when you can email me?
Oh, top right quest book.
Oh!
Claim one reward.
Press the quest?
Oh!
Oh, wait, no?
No?
No.
No...
Hahaha.
Never mind.
No.
Oh.
Hahaha.
Wait.
Guys, we're learning.
Hahaha.
Oh, they're the red puppies.
Wait, I talked to them already.
They're mailboxes?
We use dogs for mail?
I'm learning so much.
Oh, my god!
They are!
We are!
Look at these freaks.
Look at these little silly guys.
No!
Ready!
I have to wait an hour!
We got to be shubbed.
No!
Look at these non-cookie freaks!
You're not a cookie!
We use you for mail because you're not a cookie!
A genetically engineered join the post.
Did we make them like that?
Oh, we're the monster all alike!
The cake houses are built different.
Okay.
Alright.
I think we explored a lot from the kingdom.
Oh, I claim leaving town.
Yes, give me everything.
Yes!
I want it all!
I'm never satisfied!
Give it all to me!
Alright.
Let's see.
Oh.
There's apparently... Oh my god!
Who are you?
You look like the...
Like the...
The anime boy that's about to...
You know, in like anime.
They're like, you know...
They're like, I'm here to help you.
Good, because I need all the help I can get.
Oh my god!
What are you?
That's not a cookie!
Wait, is that a BTS cookie?
Oh my god!
He is!
Wait, who are you?
Oh my god!
It's Jin!
It's... Oh my god!
It's him!
Wait, what's your story?
Oh my god, it is him!
No way!
Wait, what's your story?
What's your story?
Meet everyone's darling, Jimin Cookie.
Oh my god!
Wait!
What about Mickey?
Or Goofy?
What's his lore in Cookie Run?
Where is he?
Where's Goofy?
I need to find Goofy!
No, not you!
I don't care about you!
I care about Goofy!
There's so many cookies in my kingdom!
What's up, buddy?
Stop!
Guys, there's too many cookies in my kingdom!
I'm trying to find... I'm trying to find...
I'm trying to find Goofy!
Where are you, Goofy?
What?
This is gonna be awesome!
What's your lore?
Tell us a very special, Fox.
You're not even a cookie!
Where's the cookie part?
The tails!
That's not a cookie!
Of course, now the...
Two are the best friends and the tail knows his way around.
Oh!
But with Sonic health, he has gained in...
Let's promote you.
I have...
Oh, not enough soul stones?
How many...
Upgrade.
Your skill can't exceed.
Don't worry, I got you.
Let's go.
There we go, we did it.
Now you're the...
Now you're the strongest.
Cookie out there.
Tails is met.
You will be...
You're not one star!
Met.
I'll make you the strongest cookie out there.
Alright, nice.
Now we have a strong tails.
Now clean my kingdom.
The strongest one star.
Wait, can I actually?
Okay.
Oh, it's the quiz game!
That's the newest thing!
That's the newest event!
So I'm heading over to...
It's not a game time yet.
Come back later.
In 43 minutes...
No!
It's so close!
I can't believe it.
I was just too late.
I was too busy.
Guys, I was too busy.
Leveling up tails!
I was too busy leveling up tails.
What's this?
It's also a new event.
This one.
What's this?
Combat preset or...
Apparently, you use it to combat a preset order of any ways to battle.
Earn points to receive rewards as well as try...
Oh!
I want to battle!
Battle, please.
Oh, it randomized!
Oh, it's over.
It's over for them.
It's so over.
I wish it brought tails though.
Time to fight.
It's okay.
What did I do?
It's over.
Get them out of here.
Oh my God!
Oh wait, no, no, no.
They're okay.
I did it.
Yay!
Damage received minus.
I did it!
Select a cookie to swap?
198!
That's right.
Get out of here.
Where's my tails?
I want my tails to come in!
Okay, click everything.
Click everything.
!
now replace?
More damage equals more.
More damage equals stronger.
King's blessings!
All right.
Cool down, decreased equally to increase food.
Oh, attack speed!
Wait, no, this one.
Wait, it's blue.
Wait, that was yellow.
Is yellow better than blue?
Of course, I'm yellow.
Wait, auto?
Oh.
123 more... oh, that's HP.
More attack.
More attack equals better cookie.
Don't... I will replace every cookie.
I will replace every cookie.
Oh, that's a god cookie?
Oh.
Guys, why didn't you stop me?
You could have stopped me.
You know I don't read!
Attack.
56,000.
Yes.
Boss?
It's just a cake.
Use everything.
Go, my cookies!
Go... is this speed?
Oh, wait.
That's a lot better.
See?
Look.
It's so easy.
When an ally summons...
Oh!
Yellow!
Yellow is better.
59,000?
Is it?
Where's Tiz?
198... 26,000... 183...
29,000!
This guy.
None of my characters have summons?
Eventually, it'll happen!
Bullseye!
It'll happen eventually!
Oh, my cookie's dead!
No!
Why did I choose this cookie?
Guys, why didn't you stop me?
Why...
Bullseye!
For the win!
Guys, you could have stopped me.
Bullseye!
Why are they so strong?
Is it because they're metal?
No!
My other tank is gonna die!
It has so many attacks!
But bigger number!
Are you trying to tell me bigger number doesn't mean anything?
Oh no, guys, I don't think we're gonna...
Guys, guys, he's not doing so well!
Guys, are you trying to tell me...
numbers and... strength... strength doesn't mean anything?
Is that... oh no, King, please!
They're so low, King!
Please!
Why don't you do anything?
You're level 80!
It's...
so fair!
Not without some way!
Who got to 59,000?
Is that my high score?
He doesn't need...
Oh, all he does is heal.
Oh, that makes more sense now.
Yeah, that makes a lot of sense that all he does is heal.
I'm still trying to find Goofy.
Oh gosh.
Oh, Donald!
Give the white fluffy cookie a blueberry jelly bean...
Oh my God!
He has a little cream on his...
I'm a Donald Stan.
Oh my God!
He's my BTS.
Look at him!
He has a little cream on the top of his head!
Donald, why couldn't you be...
Why weren't you there in my... in my battle?
Okay, guys, I want to put Tails in.
Let's see.
I want to go to... where's my team?
Cookies.
As the master of the Ivory Pagoda...
Whoa!
What's your story?
Apathy.
Okay.
That's your story.
Wait, is there...
Whoa!
Oh, my Max love... Oh, wait.
Where's the... I want to...
Wait, I'm missing one cookie?
Who am I missing?
I'm actually missing one cookie!
Whoa!
How could I be missing one cookie?
Hahaha!
I want to change my Lotto.
I want to change my cookie Lotto.
Okay, let's see.
Uh...
Build Kingdom Affairs.
Dashboard Shop.
Promoting...
It's Butter Roll Cookie?
What does Butter Roll Cookie look like?
I'm not Max.
Gotcha!
Where are you, Butter Roll Cookie?
Where are you?
Found, found, found, found, found, found, found, found, found, found, found, found.
I can scroll to the bottom of the list?
Wait... Oh!
The bottom of the list tells me...
Sorry, there's so many cookies.
It's CREAM FERRET!
My fingers...
It's Cream Ferret.
Hahaha!
Stupid Ferret.
Wake up!
Wait, where...
Where's the...
I'm trying to...
Events.
Okay.
There you go.
Wake up!
Hahaha!
You're my only cookie!
When did I get Butter on my pad?
Wake up!
How do I get this?
You need to complete my collection!
I don't have it!
It's I need a hundred!
Wake up!
You're supposed to babysit me!
You're literally the babysit Ferret!
I used it all up.
I used up...
Oh, you're pretending.
You're pretending to be sleeping, aren't you?
I can tell you're pretending.
I know you're pretending.
Hahaha!
I didn't have enough!
I didn't have enough, guys!
Alright, let's see.
My cookie.
Okay, I want to change up my party.
Is it... Bonds?
Best birthday...
Oh!
I have all the Bond buffs too.
That's crazy.
I need to find Tails.
I want to know...
Oh my God!
All these designs are so pretty though.
My God!
There's a pumpkin cookie!
That's not a cookie!
Hahaha!
That is not a cookie!
Where's...
Oh, there's Tails!
Oh, these are like the crossovers!
There's Sonic!
Level 31 Sonic!
There's all the promotions!
That's so cute!
Where's like the...
Where's Goofy?
Wait, where's Goofy?
Rarity...
Oh!
Okay, wait.
By rarity.
Who's the rarest?
Right here.
I can't believe I didn't get...
I can't believe it!
I can't believe I didn't...
I couldn't wake her up.
I'm so sad.
It's okay, I have Tails.
The strongest Tails out there.
You know what?
Tails is so strong...
That...
Uh...
Oh, it's like a...
Cosmetic.
Tails is so strong...
That like...
He can solo everything.
Oh no, I have no more star jellies.
I used up all of it.
I...
Hahaha!
Because...
Because I didn't read...
I never read...
Okay, I wanna...
Kingdom Arena.
What's this?
Oh!
Season 1?
Arena seasons?
Okay, I'm gonna...
Redo my team.
I wanna redo my team.
Uh...
Attackers.
Alright.
Where are you...
Where are you, Tails?
You're going in there.
Just you though.
Clear.
I calculate a disaster!
You got this, Tails.
What's the worst that can happen?
Oh, wait!
You got this, Tails.
What's...
Hahaha!
You can solo these guys!
What's the worst that can happen?
I don't know what you're talking about.
What's the...
Literally, what's the worst that can...
I have like 10.
You know that.
What's the...
There's level 2!
Literally, what's the worst that can happen?
Yes, I wish to continue.
Hahaha!
Oh, I can't move.
He's about to...
What are you gonna do, kill me?
Oh, my God, you guys did not believe in Tails!
Let's go!
Oh, absolute PM.
I'm just sending Tails.
Am I finding real people?
Tails, leave.
Wait, are these real people?
That's right!
Oh, yeah, I'm teaching these children a lesson.
That's right, children!
All I need is one kick!
Get out of here!
Should've gotcha more children!
Go gotcha more child!
And you too can be just as good as Tails!
Teach them the real mode!
I don't need to add Sonic, I can just add Tails.
Met Tails, Dayruid.
Who are you?
Level 5!
Get out of here!
Should've been the son of the creator of Cookie Run.
My dad worked hard to make this game.
He's the one who makes that Cookie Run.
Get out of here!
190 steps!
That's cute!
I did 19,000 damage.
You only got 99%!
I only got 1% of my HP.
Nice.
Yeah!
Ring up!
Alright, nice.
Alright, who else?
Oh, you got... you have some...
Oh!
Okay.
No, not you.
Alright, anyway.
Get in here and fight me!
That's right, child!
You were the first person I saw today!
Get out!
What's wrong with you?
No, no, it's just a misclick, guys.
It was a misclick.
I don't know what to...
I want my next fight!
Oh my God!
What are you doing here?
Yeah, where are you?
You two do not...
You know damn well...
A million of power...
Oh, 107?
Ha, ha, ha!
Ha, ha!
You have a hundred and...
7000!
Wait, actually...
I don't know, this is a little risky.
This is just a little risky.
I don't think Tails will make it.
Okay, they haven't healed it.
Okay, you're right.
Maybe I'll just bully this guy.
Get out!
Taro!
There you go!
Easy!
Another 1%!
Nice!
Oh my god!
Easiest fight of my life!
Oh!
T-Frontz won!
Where did these guys...
You know what?
I can...
Oh, 13.
Oh, you spent so much money on these two characters!
Clearly not enough!
Go back and spend more money!
That's right!
Oh, what happened to your healer?
Oh, that's cute!
Oh!
Wait, I can't move!
Wait a minute!
That's cute!
I'm gonna roll in it!
I'm gonna go in 8 seconds!
And destroy your healer!
I don't need heals!
In 1 second!
Oh, what happened to your healer, little guy?
That's right!
Get out of my game!
Get out!
It has 80 bucks.
It's so over.
Okay, I got rid of their support.
That's all that matters.
My ranking?
Oh, wait...
Who put these babies in here?
What the hell is this?
The hell is supremacy?
Who put these...
There we go.
We don't need Sonic!
All we need is our really strong tails!
That is overkill on that support.
How did you get in my elo?
The Doki train does not stop!
Rink up!
Silver 3!
Oh, the default Dan?
Oh, you have default Dan?
Should have gotcha'd more!
You should have gotcha'd more!
Get out, default Dan!
Alright, nice.
I'm not smurfing!
This is literally my first time playing.
Alright.
I'm not smurfing!
This is my first time playing this game!
I'm just that good!
I'm literally just... I'm that guy!
Oh, you have a tiger?
That's right, you had a tiger!
Why that 200k?
What 200k team?
I don't know what you're talking about.
I'm just that good.
I'm already at silver 2.
I don't know what you're talking...
What the heck!
2 million!
Bro, they have the whole god army!
Who put this guy in here?
2... 2 million!
This is silver 2!
What are you doing here?
It's silver 2!
Oh my god, this is like a whole baby!
Look at how tiny they are!
Alright, this is my last battle card.
And then I get kicked out.
Fight that whip!
He's here for you!
There we go.
Back to the babies.
Yay!
Alright, I used up all my cards.
I used up all my cards.
Alright guys.
I can't fight any more of the children anymore guys.
Wait, unless...
UNLESS!
HAHAHAHAHA!
HAHA!
PAY TO FIGHT MORE CHILDREN!
LET'S GO!
HAHAHAHAHA!
JK!
I have the money to fight more!
HAHAHAHAHA!
HAHAHA!
That's right.
Goodbye!
Hey!
Nice!
Go Tails!
Go!
I don't know if I can like...
When do I...
When does the curse stop?
The ride never ends.
HAHAHAHA!
What's the lowest?
Oh, the gnome.
We can't fast forward?
We don't even get to see them fight?
Fast forward.
Yeah, I think I...
Yeah, I think...
HAHAHA!
I think it's...
We know what's gonna happen on this one too.
You don't even deserve me watching it cause we know what's gonna happen.
Goodbye.
HAHAHA!
Yeah!
Yay!
How did you...
Default dead with the...
One guy!
With the one guy!
You know what?
No, let's watch you.
Let's...
You know what?
I feel a little generous here.
Where's Tuxedo Man?
Where are you?
What color is Tuxedo Man?
HAHAHA!
The...
The bat...
Oh wait, it's a costume, right?
That's a...
Bait tea.
HAHAHA!
It's a costume, right?
Okay.
I need to remove you.
Uh...
HAHAHA!
Alright.
I don't want...
It's...
Does he...
It's a costume, right guys?
Spearman's top 500 goals right here.
Oh, I'm so sorry.
Alright.
You know what?
Let's go.
There's no way.
I got put on the costume.
I'll be right back.
HAHAHA!
I'm not done with you.
I'll be right back.
HAHAHA!
Where are you?
Follow my lead!
Nooo!
Okay, wait.
There we go.
We did so much together.
Nice.
There we go.
No, no!
Alright, child!
I'm coming back in!
That's right, child!
That's right.
Oh, that's cute!
618 versus 22,000!
Missed the meeting!
The mirror match of the ages!
Who will win?
Yay!
I'm gold too!
Yippee!
I'm gold!
Gold too!
Oh my god, with the 2 million!
Where are these... where's the children?
There we go, there's the children.
Alright, get back in here.
I'm done playing with you.
I'm done playing with you, gal.
Alright, we all know what's gonna happen.
There's no way.
Nice!
Alright, I just wanna make sure...
I just wanna weed out the children out of here.
So that everybody else will... WHAT?!
No!
How?!
How do I...
What happened?
What?
How did they...
How did they stop me?
Is it cause they...
OHHHH!
That's how they stopped me!
They fought back!
The children fought back!
No...
How did they stop Tails?
70 D-Bucks...
Cause their power level is 57,000!
Of course I would fight him!
My win streak...
They...
This is not fair.
I can't even... I can't even rematch them!
I can't... I can't even...
What is your name?
I will remember you.
Thank you!
Alright.
Well that was fun.
That was really fun.
I...
I had a great time.
Honestly.
That was fun trying out...
Cookie Run for the very first time.
You know what?
No, we don't end on a loss.
You're right guys.
We don't end on a loss.
Who's the... Refreshing.
Alright.
We don't end on a loss.
You're right.
We don't...
You're absolutely right.
Let me...
Let me go all...
You're right everybody.
You're right.
This is how we are ending.
Hey!
Hello.
We did it!
Yay!
Alright.
And that's how...
And that's how we end the stream.
That's how...
It's not overkill.
If the children...
My dad works at Cookie Run.
But yes.
That was the new update.
I hope you guys had a...
Fun time.
I had a great time trying out for the first time.
Again...
Huge shout out to Cookie Run for...
For the sponsor.
If you guys want to support this stream...
And support the game as well...
Feel free to check the link out in the description.
And the pinned message.
Download and install the game.
It really does help a lot guys.
I...
It was really really fun.
And I definitely enjoyed it a lot.
So thank you again.
Thank you guys.
I hope you guys had a fun time watching.
I understand why this game is incredibly popular.
Especially the designs.
The designs.
The designs are...
The designs are really really pretty.
I have to admit.
I really like looking at all the character designs.
Of the cookies.
And obviously...
So much love being put into this game.
So yes.
Thank you again.
As always everybody.
Stay hydrated.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me.
Head to bed.
Because you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time everybody.
Bye guys.